TV RAMAN: Welcome, everyone.
Thank you for coming to this
talk on Android accessibility
and the second day of I/O. Hope
you had a great party
last night and are ready
for a whole sequence
of talks this morning.
My name is TV Raman.
I've been working on Android and
Chrome accessibility for
the last few years.
And with me I have Casey
Burkhardt and Alan Viverette
who also work on Android
accessibility.
A quick intro to what we're
going to be talking about.
So this is about Android
accessibility, and we've
billed this as an advanced
developer talk.
Android accessibility
is a core part
of the Android framework.
And the way you should think of
what that core capability,
the framework, does is think of
it as mechanisms that are
built into the platform, so that
you as a developer can
reach the largest
number of users.
You heard some fairly
amazing numbers
in the keynote yesterday.
I can never remember
the numbers.
I think it was about
900 million Android
devices out there now.
By the time we are done during
this talk, it's probably 902
million at the rate at
which things grow
What is Android as a platform
giving you the developer?
It's giving you the developer
the ability to write these
wonderfully innovative apps that
can run on a very large
variety of devices.
So you don't have to worry about
different screen sizes,
5 inches versus 4 1/2 inches
versus 5 1/2 inches.
You don't have to worry about
does this phone have a
keyboard or not, all
of those things.
Think of the other half of the
equation, the people who use
your applications.
Today, most of you are probably
targeting your
applications at users who have
perfect vision, who have
perfect hand-eye coordination,
who can use the
touch screen well.
In a sense, you are not having
to focus as much
on the user's abilities.
What we, from the accessibility
side of Android,
do is to make sure that you can
continue to focus on your
app, on the core part
of your part.
And the Android platform just
does the heavy lifting for you
in terms of making sure that
your app just works for all
your users.
But life's never that
simple, right?
If you had to code your app all
the way from the beginning
to worry about the blind user,
the low-vision user, the deaf
user, the motion-impaired
user, you would
have a very hard time.
Our goal is to make that
really, really easy.
And for core platform APIs,
everything we talk about today
will be in the context of low
vision and blindness.
But the way it does architected,
when you address
these use cases, you actually
will be covering a lot more
use cases, all the way from
one button controls for
somebody who's severely
motion-impaired to the blind
user who cannot see at all.
We've done previous talks about
the core accessibility
layer in Android.
And I highly recommend our talk
from last year which gave
a very detailed overview of
the features in Jellybean.
This year, what we will do is
Casey will first take you
quickly through some of the
accessibility basics as a
quick revision.
And then Alan will go through
in detail about the next
level, which is what if
you're designing an
entirely a custom UI.
As I said the Android platform
with its built-in
accessibility, with its built-in
view layer, has
accessibility support
for all the widgets.
But what if you've decided to
create a completely new
experience?
How do you easily make
that then accessible.
So that will be the second
half of this talk.
We will have office hours.
We will give you details on the
office hours again towards
the end of the talk.
We also have a sandbox
downstairs where you can see
accessibility technologies both
from us at Google as well
as from our partners.
So enjoy the talk.
I look forward to your
questions at the end.
And take it away, Casey.
CASEY BURKHARDT: Thanks Raman.
Hi, everyone.
I'm Casey Burkhardt.
I'm a software engineer
on the Accessibility
Engineering Team at Google.
And as Raman mentioned, I'm
going to go through some of
the accessibility basics
on Android.
So accessibility is
exposed through
accessibility services.
The framework provides
information about user
interaction to these services
through objects called
accessibility events.
These are presented as
accessibility services which
had a privilege level that's a
bit higher than other services
to receive information about
this user interaction.
So we get information about
notification, movement of
focus, how the user interacts
with apps.
And the accessibility service
is responsible for providing
feedback for that.
We ship two accessibility
services right now.
The first is TalkBack, which
is a screen reader that's
optimized for the
touch screen.
What we do is we allow for
different types of navigation
throughout your application
and throughout Android.
We allow random access through
a feature called
ExploreByTouch, which allows a
users to use a single finger
to interrogate the screen
and explore what
they're currently touching.
The accessibility service gets
information about that
interaction and provides
feedback to the user.
We also provide access to this
onscreen content linearly.
So if a user is unfamiliar with
an interface, they can
navigate it item by item
to see everything
that's on the screen.
TalkBack provides all this
feedback through
text-to-speech as well as
vibration feedback and
auditory icons.
But we also ship another
service, BrailleBack, which
works in a similar way but
provides feedback on a
refreshable Braille display.
So this is a device that
connects to the Android phone
or tablet through Bluetooth and
actually changes its state
of little actuator pins,
so the user can read
Braille on the fly.
The user can also click on
individual cells which result
in click actions being sent to
the view that represents the
text from that cell and can also
pan through the entire
onscreen content to
see everything
that's on the screen.
Most of these Braille devices
also include a built-in
keyboard, so the user
can even enter text.
All of these things combine to
allow the user to drive the
phone or tablet from inside
their pocket just with this
Braille display.
A key tenet of accessibility in
Jellybean and above is the
idea of accessibility focus.
It works just like system input
focus, but it's assigned
by an accessibility focused to
any view in the interface.
So as a user interacts with the
device, the service gets
events about the interaction and
can decide to assign focus
to anywhere in the
user interface.
Focus is indicated by this
yellow highlight you see
around the clock widget here.
And when something receives
focus, the service is intended
to speak or provide some sort
of feedback to the user.
Focus is also the point of
interaction for any events or
actions that occur from
that point forward.
So for example, if I double tap
while this widget receives
focus, the clock widget will
receive a click event.
If I double tap and hold my
finger down, the [INAUDIBLE]
will receive a long click
event, and so forth.
So it's up to the accessibility
service about
how to assign this focus.
In TalkBack, we use a heuristic
based on whether a
view is actionable or not to
determine focusability.
So what we do is we take a look
at the view hierarchy.
We see that a view is either
clickable or focusable, and we
mark that view as a candidate
to receive
accessibility focus.
When we traverse the hierarchy,
we take these
candidates and we assign focus
to them in the order that the
user intends through
their interaction.
And failing to find actionable
content, we fall back to
actual text content.
So if you don't have focusable
or clickable content in your
application, but you still have
text or labeled images,
we'll focus those as well.
So here's an example of that.
What we have here is the folder
widget from the home
screen that comes default in
most stock Android devices.
And what we're interested here
in is a folder icon.
You see the folder icon object,
outlined in yellow in
this hierarchy viewer tree,
is the current node with
accessibility focus.
When TalkBack traverses the
hierarchy, we see that this
view is clickable.
So we say oh, this is an actual
piece of content.
We should give it accessibility
focus.
When the user navigates to this
point in the hierarchy,
we select this view, search
down and traverse its
children, and populate speech
with the content of its
children nodes.
So for this example, the image
view is labeled with the
content description--
folder--
and the bubble text view
has the text--
Google.
So TalkBack will speak
Folder, Google.
So now let's switch over to a
demo, and we'll quickly show
how TalkBack will work with your
application, how users
will use ExploreByTouch and
linear navigation to move
through your user interface.
And then we'll do a quick demo
of Braille and introduce our
new virtual Braille display.
So here we have an Android
device running the latest
version of Jellybean.
All accessibility on the
platform can be enabled
through a common location.
It lives in Settings,
Accessibility.
And you can see it lists all
the services that are
currently installed.
Here we have TalkBack
and BrailleBack.
To enable a service, just tap it
and flip its switch to on.
You'll receive a warning that
it's a privileged service.
It can do things like retrieve
interaction events and get
onscreen content.
You accept the warning, and the
service is now running.
As I navigate through the user
interface with a single
finger, I can actually get
feedback for the content that
I'm currently touching.
ANDROID: When TalkBack is on,
your device provides spoken
feedback to help blind
and low-vision users.
For example, it describes
what you touch--
CASEY BURKHARDT: So I covered
the proximity sensor to
Silence Speech.
I can continue to navigate
around the interface--
ANDROID: When TalkBack
is on, on switch--
3.5 [? g-note ?].
CASEY BURKHARDT: Let's
now stop TalkBack.
ANDROID: OK.
Cancel but--
Settings.
CASEY BURKHARDT: To activate
something in the interface--
ANDROID: When TalkBack is on--
CASEY BURKHARDT: I
give it focus--
ANDROID: Settings.
CASEY BURKHARDT: And
I double tap.
ANDROID: TalkBack Settings.
CASEY BURKHARDT: That sends a
click event to that button,
and fires the Click Listener,
and opens TalkBack Settings.
If I'm unfamiliar with this
interface, I can actually
navigate it item by item.
And here's how I do that.
I just do that with a series
of Swype gestures.
ANDROID: TalkBack Settings.
Speech.
Speech Volume.
Match media volume.
CASEY BURKHARDT: And so forth.
I can move back by Swyping
the opposite direction.
ANDROID: Speech.
CASEY BURKHARDT: We also provide
quick access to common
system functions, like pulling
down the notification shade.
ANDROID: Notification shade.
CASEY BURKHARDT:
Or going back.
ANDROID: TalkBack settings.
CASEY BURKHARDT: We also have a
great tool called the Global
Context Menu, which allows a
user to quickly access common
tasks within TalkBack.
For example, it's very important
sometimes to be able
to read all the content
on the screen at once.
ANDROID: Touch the screen and
explore in a circle to find an
item, then lift to select.
Read from top.
TalkBack settings.
Speech.
Speech volume.
Match media volume.
Use pitch changes.
Speak keyboard feedback and--
speech.
CASEY BURKHARDT: And
I'll touch the
screen to silence it.
ANDROID: Speech volume.
Match media--
CASEY BURKHARDT: So you can see
that accessibility moved
on its own.
It would read through the entire
user interface and
describe to the user
what's there.
This is a great tool for
developers too, because it
allows them to open up an
activity, enable reading from
top, look at each item as it
receives accessibility focus,
and ensure that the spoken
description is
accurate for that item.
If something's unlabeled,
mislabeled, or doesn't receive
accessibility focus, it's really
easy to tell which
widget you need to look into
to improve the experience.
So in addition to TalkBack,
we have BrailleBack.
Let's enable that.
ANDROID: Back, Settings, Back,
Accessibility, Show--
BrailleBack off.
Settings.
Off switch.
Alert use BrailleBack.
OK button.
Settings.
CASEY BURKHARDT: So now
BrailleBack is running.
And I've actually enabled in
BrailleBack Settings, which
you can get by clicking the
Settings button there, a
virtual Braille display.
So because we don't have a
refreshable Braille display
connected through Bluetooth
right now, it's incredibly
useful to be able to see what's
on a virtual display
especially for developers.
So what we see here is an
overlay on the bottom of the
screen that actually shows what
would appear on a Braille
display with its human readable
translation below in
actual ASCII text.
So this gives you an idea of,
if you navigate through your
interface, what your users
will see on the Braille
display when they're using
your application.
ANDROID: Navigate up.
On switch.
CASEY BURKHARDT: So you can see
that the display updates.
ANDROID: When BrailleBack
is on--
CASEY BURKHARDT: OK.
ANDROID: Alert.
CASEY BURKHARDT: Great.
Another great feature of
TalkBack is you can turn it
off really quickly.
You go back to the Global
Context Menu and just go to a
Pause Feedback.
ANDROID: Pause Feedback.
CASEY BURKHARDT: And it's off.
OK.
So let's talk briefly about what
you as developers need to
do to make your applications
successful.
All of this content is
in our previous years
talk in greater detail.
So I encourage you, if you're
interested, go back and look
at those talks from 2011 and
2012 regarding Android
accessibility.
You'll get this content
in more depth.
The first thing to know about
accessibility within native
applications is that the widgets
that ship with the
platform, as part of
the SDK, are all
accessible to begin with.
A lot of time is gone into
instrumenting these for
accessibility, and we provide a
really great experience for
all the built-in widgets.
So whenever possible, use
built-in widgets within your
application.
If you do need to create a
custom widget, some class of
view that is as deep in the
class hierarchy as possible,
so you get the benefit of having
the accessibility bits
in that widget.
So there are some widgets that
need a little extra care.
And these are widgets that are
essentially nontext-based, in
particular, Image View
and Image button.
Because there's no textual
content to speaker put on a
Braille display for a user, it's
important that you as the
developer provide one.
This is done through the
android:setContentDescription
attribute in your layout.
And you'll want to make sure
you provide a translatable
stream for that.
If you have a view that's
entirely decorative and
probably isn't important for
accessibility, you can set a
content description null.
This will do two things.
It will fix all your
lint errors.
You'll see your link warnings
because of lack of content
descriptions.
And it will also indicate to
accessibility services that
their concept probably
isn't worth receiving
accessibility focus.
If you have content that
updates throughout the
lifecycle of your
application--
for example, a play/pause button
that changes state--
you can use the
View.SetContentDescription
method to dynamically
update the view
when its meaning changes.
And finally, if you've got one
view that is intended to label
another and has an appropriate
description, you can use the
Android label for attribute to
indicate to TalkBack or other
accessibility services that
you're providing a label
through another view.
If you have a hybrid application
or use web content
within your application,
be sure to use W3C web
accessibility initiatives,
standards and guidelines to
ensure that the web content
is accessible.
We do provide access to web
content for accessibility
services through an injected
version of ChromeVox.
There was a talk on
that yesterday.
And stop by our sandbox
to see a demo.
And if you find yourself in a
situation where you do have to
write an entirely custom widget
yourself, there are
framework APIs that allow you
to do this, but it does
require a good bit
of extra work.
The good news, though,
is it can be done.
And the better news is we've
created a helper class that
helps you do that.
For purposes of example,
we'll use a custom
view that we've created.
It's bar graph view.
This view is constructed and
populated with a title that
you see on top there and a set
of data and an interray where
each value in that array
represents the value of a bar
in the bar graph.
So the user can click on
bars to highlight them.
And we actually draw all of
the content from this view
with on draw.
There's no internal views
that are used.
We actually render the text
to a canvas, so we're not
actually using a Text View at
all within this application.
We also really set it focusable,
or provide any sort
of description initially.
And for click events, we
actually don't use a standard
click listener, we listen for
touch events and implement our
own click listener.
So this is basically a perfect
storm for accessibility.
When you interrogate this view
with TalkBack and you move
focus to it, it speaks
nothing.
In fact, it doesn't even receive
focus, because there's
no actual content to speak.
This is an example of really
the worst case scenario for
the accessible user, when they
try to use your application
and there's a view that's
just entirely empty.
Luckily, we have an answer--
an easy way for you as
developers to make this widget
accessible.
So I'll hand it off to Alan
who's going to demonstrate our
new helper class.
ALAN VIVERETTE: Thanks, Casey.
Hi, I'm Alan Viverette.
I'm a software engineer on
the accessibility team.
And I'll be showing you how you
can make your custom views
totally accessible,
support all of the
features in Jelly Bean.
But first, who here has
written an Android
application?
Quite a few.
Awesome.
So who here's written custom
views for an Android
application?
Still quite a lot of people.
So if you're just using standard
widgets, you're off
to a really good start.
If you're using custom views,
you have a little bit more
work to do.
But first, let's take a
step back and think
about what's in a view?
So we've got our sample
bar graph on screen.
And visually, it's somewhere
on the screen.
It's got some dimensions.
It has some information that
it's conveying to the user,
here through both graphics
and text.
And it has an interaction
model.
So I can click on these bars
to change what's displayed.
But each of these bars has
its own dimensions and
positioning.
It has its own information
that it's
conveying to the user.
It has its own interaction.
Each bar is individually
clickable.
And because we're not extending
view group and using
subviews, we actually have to
expose this to accessibility
services some other way.
So now let's move to
accessibility node info, which
is how an accessibility service
sees the views in your
application.
Again, you have dimensions
and positioning.
You have some sort of
information that you're
conveying to the user.
You have some sort of
interaction model-- clicking,
long clicking, scrolling,
et cetera.
And most importantly,
we have child nodes.
So even if your view isn't a
view group and doesn't have
subviews, You can still expose
extra accessibility node info
as children of your
top level view.
So that's what we're
going to do here.
Each bar is going to have an
accessibility node info that
exposes its information to
an accessibility service.
How do we do that?
There's an accessibility node
provider class built into the
framework that allows you to
create new nodes and expose
those to the framework.
So here we've got--
oh, it looks like the
sample code doesn't
all fit on the screen.
Let's shrink that down a bit.
Oh, we're still able to fit
everything on the screen.
It looks like there's a lot of
code that's required to use an
accessibility node provider.
And in fact, there are about
12 more slides of this that
I'm not going to go through.
Instead, we've made an
accessibility helper class
called ExploreByTouch helper.
This is going to simplify
creating and exposing a
virtual view hierarchy,
with just five
simple abstract methods.
This still wraps
AccessibilityNod
eProviderCompat, which means
there's a lot of code on the
back end that you won't have
to look at, fortunately.
This also means it's going to
work out of the box with
screen readers, with Braille
displays, and with some
interfaces that you may have
never even seen before, like
some Sip-and-Puff
or SingleSwitch.
Most importantly, this
is backwards
compatible with API 4.
So even if you're targeting
Doughnut, you can still have
full Jellybean quality
accessibility in your
application.
So how do we start using the
ExploreByTouchHelper class?
Well, first, we're going to need
to delegate handling of
certain events, both
accessibility events and touch
events for when touch
exploration is turned on.
We're going to actually map the
touch events from touch
exploration to logical items
within our view.
In this case, they'll be bars.
And we're going to need to
expose information about these
bars to accessibility
services.
So these are things like
positioning and size on
screen, actions that are
supported and informational
content, in the form of
a content description.
We're also going to need to
provide support for user
interaction.
So a user can click on a bar,
and we need to have some way
to interact with that, change
what's displayed on screen,
and let the framework know
what's going on.
And finally, we're going to
test our application.
We're going to make sure that
the same information that's
displayed visually is exposed to
accessibility services and
can be spoken out loud
or displayed it
on a Braille display.
So first, let's move over to the
device and take a look at
the application with
accessibility turned off.
We've got our pretty blue
graph on the screen.
We can touch them and
they turn yellow.
We can see that it says bar
graph inaccessible.
And for each bar, we can see how
high it is compared to the
other bars.
Let's turn on accessibility.
ANDROID: Bar Graph I/O 2013.
ALAN VIVERETTE: And as Casey
mentioned, we're just going to
Read From Top to read everything
on the screen.
ANDROID: Bar graph I/--
Touch the Read From Top.
Bar graph I/O 2013.
ALAN VIVERETTE: And it's done.
So obviously, we're missing
some content here.
We'd probably like to read
Bar Graph Inaccessible.
And we'd like to get some
information out of these bars
that are shown on screen.
So let's start implementing
some support for
accessibility, using our
TouchHelper class.
The first thing we need to do,
as I mentioned, is delegate
accessibility support.
So we're first going to create a
new BarGraphTouchhelper that
extends our ExploreByTouchHelper
class.
We'll go into the implementation
details on that
in just a moment.
But the first thing we're
going to do is delegate
responsibility for accessibility
to this class
using ViewCompat.setAc
cessibilityDelegate.
We're also going to dispatch
hover events first to our
TouchHelper class, because when
ExploreByTouch is turned
on, touching the screen is
translated into hover events.
We need to handle these hover
events specially to let the
framework know if we're touching
a logical item.
So we're delegating in
two places here.
And once we've done that, we can
start thinking about the
implementation for our class.
One thing that we're going to
need to worry about is mapping
our logical items to something
that the framework
understands.
In this case, the framework is
going to use a virtual view id
to reference our
logical items.
So every view in the framework,
every actual view,
has a virtual view ID
that gets computed.
We're going to provide our own
virtual view IDs so that when
the framework says, could you
give me the first child and
the second child, the third
child, we know what they're
talking about.
We have to make some guarantees
about these virtual
view ids, namely, that they're
one-to-one, which means for
every virtual view ID, there is
only one logical item that
it refers to.
And for every logical item, it
has only one virtual view ID.
We're also going to make sure
that they're stable, which
means that when we refer to
virtual view id 0, it's always
going to refer to the
same logical item.
We also have to make sure that
they're non-negative.
there's certain negative virtual
view ids that are used
internally by the framework.
So we have half range, which
is a good amount of
virtual view ids.
For a bar graph view, we can
actually just reuse the data
rate indices.
So we passed in an interray when
we were creating it, and
we're displaying these bars on
screen in the order that they
are in in the interray.
So our first bar, index 0,
is at the very far left.
We can go ahead and assign
that virtual view id 0.
We can maintain this mapping for
all of the array indices
in their array, because it's
one-to-one, it's stable, and
because it's an array index,
it has to be non-negative.
So we'll just map directly,
virtual view id,
index within the array.
Now that we have a mapping, we
can start to expose some of
the on screen content to
accessibility services.
So the first thing we're
going to do is override
getVirtualViewIdAt.
This is the first of five
methods that we've be
overriding in this class.
We're going to take an xy
coordinate on the screen in
view relative coordinates, so 0,
0 is the top left of my bar
graph view.
And we're going to reuse the
same method we used for hit
detection in onTouchEvent.
So you noticed during the demo
with accessibility turned off,
I could touch a bar and
it would change color.
That's because I'm overriding
onTouchEvent in my view.
I'm taking the xy coordinate,
figuring out which bar the
user is touching and changing
some of its properties.
So we can just reuse this
method, return to the
index in the array.
Because I'm mapping directly
for indexed to virtual view
id, I just check to see whether
I got a valid index.
If I did, I return it.
If I didn't, I return
the special constant
ExploreByTouchHe
lper.INVALID_ID.
And what this tells the
ExploreByTouchHelper class is
that the user touched the
screen, but they didn't touch
any of the logical items within
my view, which means
most likely the touch will
fall to the view itself.
If it's not handled by the view
itself, it might fall
under that.
We're also going to override
getVisibleVirtualViewIds,
method two of five that we'll
be overriding, and this lets
the framework know both the
items that are visible on
screen through virtual
view IDs.
And the order in which we'd like
them to be navigated by
Swype navigation.
So as long as I populate this 0
1 2 3 4, as the user swipes
right, they'll hit bar 0, bar
1, bar 2, bar 3, in order.
If I have something more
complicated, say I have two
rows of bars and maybe I want
to do the first bar, the
second bar, the third
bar, the fourth bar.
As long as I pass those into
the array in the same order
that I want them to be
navigated, that's what the
user will see.
So now we have those two down,
what else do we need to do?
Well, once a user touches
something, TalkBack is going
to speak, BrailleBack
is going to display
something on the screen.
We need to expose information
that we convey to the user.
So the first thing we need to
think about is what type of
information.
When something is spoken out
loud, you have to think about
the efficiency and the
importance of the items that
you're trying to convey.
So here each bar has
two properties--
its indexes within the array--
where it's displayed
on screen--
and its value.
And we want when a user touches
the screen at random
them to know where they
are, what type of
items they're touching.
So we're going to
say bar first.
Bar is really short, and so a
user, if they're moving around
the screen very quickly, isn't
going to have to wait very
long to know what they're
touching.
And if they're trying to
distinguish between different
bars on screen, they'll very
quickly hear the index.
So we'll speak something
like bar 0, value 5.
And because we have a
highlighted state, we're going
to provide a separate content
description that says
something like bar 0,
value 5 highlighted.
We've just written a quick
helper method here that takes
an index within the array,
gets the value, check the
highlighted property, and
populates the right template,
returns a string.
We're going to use that string
to populate a content
description for a accessibility
event.
So this is the third method
that we're overriding,
populateEventForVirtualViewId.
Accessibility events are used
by the framework to let the
accessibility service know
what's going on your
application.
So for example, when you click
on a view, there's a view
click to that.
When you scroll, there's
a view scrolled event.
We're going to populate these
with the right content
description for the logical item
that's sending the event.
We also need to expose a little
bit more information
about nodes.
We can expose the content
description as we did in the
accessibility event.
We're also going to
expose the user
interactions that are supported.
And here, you may remember, I
was able to tap on a bar to
change its properties.
So we're going to add
a click event.
So that if the user double taps
on the screen, or if a
user clicks on their Braille
display, it will have the same
behavior as if I had tapped it
with accessibility turned off.
We're also going to set the
bounds within the parent view
using getBoundsForIndex.
Now this is the same method that
we're using in onDraw to
figure out where to draw the bar
onscreen when we fill it
with that blue color and
occasionally we fill it with
that yellow highlight.
And this is going to ensure
consistency with our onDraw,
so that exactly where you touch
on screen is exactly
where our yellow focus highlight
will be placed and
exactly where you'll get
feedback for a logical item.
So you may notice,
we're reusing
methods pretty heavily.
And this is why it's so easy to
use ExploreByTouchHelper to
implement accessibility
in your custom view.
All right, so now that we've
exposed properties about our
items, let's take another look
at our application and see how
it looks with accessibility
turned on now.
All right, so we'll switch
over to our bar graph
interactive and, when I
do Read All From Top--
ANDROID: Read from top.
Bar graph 1/0 2013.
Bar 0, value minus 5.
Bar 1, value minus 4.
Bar 2, value minus 2.
Bar 3, value 0.
Bar 4, value 2.
Bar 5, value 4.
Bar 6, value 5.
ALAN VIVERETTE: All right.
So we're reading out the
bar descriptions.
That's great.
We've got the yellow focus
highlight onscreen.
That's awesome.
Let's touch it and make sure
that it works correctly.
ANDROID: Bar 5, bar
4, bar 3, bar 1.
Value minus 4.
ALAN VIVERETTE: Right?
Everything seems pretty close.
But we're missing one important
thing here.
That's the title of
the bar graph.
So we need some way to expose
this to the user.
We're going to do this--
oh, sorry, the next thing we're
going to do is Respond
To Actions.
So we're going to be
able to click on a
view by double tapping.
So when we added our
ACTION_CLICK in populate node,
we need to also handle that
later by overriding the
performActionForVirtualViewID
method.
We're going to use the same
method we used in onTouchEvent
to actually perform
the bar click.
So we've got onBar clicked.
This is going to invalidate the
view so that it's redrawn
with the highlight.
This is going to change the
internal highlight state, so
that we can draw that bar
with a different color.
And that's the only action
that we need to handle,
because that's the only
action then we
added in populate node.
We also need to let the
framework know that the action
happened successfully.
So we're going to invalidate
the virtual view id because
we're changing the
highlight state.
We're changing a property
of the virtual view.
And we're going to send an event
for that virtual view
that lets the framework know it
performed a click action.
So we send event for virtual
view ID, which is a method on
our TouchHelper class, with
TYPE_VIEW_CLICKED.
This will provide feedback in
the framework, a little haptic
feedback and a little auditory
feedback, that lets it know
and lets the user know that
something happened.
So now we have support for user
interaction, do one last
thing and go back
to the device.
So we already read through.
We noticed that we're
missing one thing.
Let's make sure that
touching--
ANDROID: Bar 5, value 4.
ALAN VIVERETTE: --and clicking
work correctly.
So we're good there, and now
if we touch the bar again,
ANDROID: Bar 5, value
4 highlighted.
ALAN VIVERETTE: All right.
And we hear highlighted.
So we're good to go there.
We have one thing missing
that I mentioned.
When we touch the bar graph
itself, we should really be
reading bar graph interactive.
And we might want to provide
some additional information to
the user just to give them an
idea of what's onscreen there.
So we're going to polish
the user experience.
We're going to add another
string that describes the bar
graph view itself.
So we're going to populate the
string with the title of the
bar graph, the type of widget
that it is, and the number of
bars that are on the screen.
The ordering here is
very important.
So when I touch the bar graph,
what I really want to know is
what is it that I'm touching?
It's a bar graph with a title.
If I have multiple bar graphs
onscreen, the most important
thing to me is going to be
what's shown in that bar
graph, what's the title.
The second most important thing
is the type of widget.
It's a bar graph, which lets
me know that it's going to
contain a couple of subviews
and the type of information
that will be seen.
I'm also going to say how
many bars are shown.
This is a little extra.
And this just tells the user
how many things they can
expect to touch when they're
moving their finger across the
screen or Swyping
left and right.
So we have a setTitle method
that we've implemented on our
bar graph view.
This sets the internal title
which is drawn onscreen.
This invalidates the view,
which redraws the title.
And we're going to set the
content description based on
the bar count by populating
this template that we've
created with the title
and bar count.
So now we've tested and we've
ensured the same information
that we can see visually
onscreen is communicated to an
accessibility service, let's go
back to the application and
do Read All From Top
to make sure that
everything makes sense.
ANDROID: Bar graph I/--
Read From Top.
Bar graph I/O 2013.
Bar graph Accessible.
Showing seven bars.
Bar 0, value minus 5.
ALAN VIVERETTE: And we
just saw this so I'm
going to skip it.
But as you can see, my bar graph
view, despite not being
a view group, not having any
views inside of it, is now
totally transparently
accessible
using Jellybean APIs.
And this runs on Doughnut.
It won't have the same Jellybean
accessibility.
But your application will
still compile and run
perfectly fine.
So just to summarize the
ExploreByTouchHelper class, it
looked like it was going to be
really difficult to implement
custom view accessibility.
But it's actually really easy.
It's five methods that
you override.
And you're just reusing things
that you've already written
for the visual aspect
of your application.
So to conclude the talk, writing
accessible Android
applications is actually very
easy, especially if you're
using built-in Android widgets,
adding content
descriptions where appropriate,
maybe you're
associating labels
with controls.
If you're using custom views,
you may want to use the
ExploreByTouchHelper class
to simplify things--
a very easy way to make your
application accessible.
And if you're using web content,
just follow best
practices for web
accessibility.
Now if you do all of these
things, your application is
going to be accessible
to more users.
Every Android phone has
accessibility baked in.
If you pull out your phone,
you go to Settings
Accessibility, you can turn
on TalkBack yourself
and you can try this.
If you have a Braille display,
or if you don't have a Braille
display, you can use the overlay
to check BrailleBack
with your application.
There are also various other
ways of interacting with the
device, including Sip-and-Puff
interfaces and switch access.
If it works with TalkBack, if
it works with BrailleBack,
there's a very good chance that
it'll work perfectly with
these alternate interfaces.
So Android's built-in
accessibility support
guarantees that if you have good
accessibility, you have a
good application, and you have
good usability for everyone,
you'll have a larger
user base.
You'll have happier users.
So I hope everybody learned
something here today.
You can check out the source
code from the slides on
eyes-free.googlecode.com.
We've got demos in the sandbox
here on a second floor.
And we've got office
hours immediately
following the talk.
We also have plenty of
time for questions.
So please stand at the
microphones in the aisles if
you have any questions, and
we will answer them.
Thanks again.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]
ALAN VIVERETTE: Any questions?
AUDIENCE: My name
is Steve Jacobs.
And I really don't
have a question.
I'm not even a developer.
But we have an Android
development company.
And one thing that wasn't
mentioned during the session
is the business driver behind
accessible design, above and
beyond accommodating the access
needs of people with
disabilities.
And you could tell I'm an
accessibility advocate.
But if you look at our global
market and you look at the top
five highest potential markets,
they spell cyber--
C-I-B-I-R--
China, India, Brazil Indonesia
and Russia.
If you look at the number of
people who never learned to
read, this can help them.
If you look at the number of
people who are aging, like me,
you're talking half
a billion people.
A billion and a half or more
people never learned to read.
There are English language
learners.
Being able to highlight text
as it's being read, using
text-to-speech can help them.
In addition to people with
print disabilities--
and we're not just talking
about blindness and other
vision impairments--
but learning disabilities,
cognitive disabilities,
mobility disabilities, and
learning disabilities, which
represents about 25% of
students in class.
50% of students taking math
have difficulty with math.
Accompanying learning math with
text-to-speech, having
images read out, having text
highlighted, having math
formulas read to you actually
strengthens the learning
experience.
So accessibility is about far
more than just accommodating
people with disabilities.
And I wanted to make sure that
the message got out loud and
clear during this session.
So I hope you don't mind my
taking the mic to say that.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]
TV RAMAN: Thank you for
saying that, Steve.
And to echo what Steve said,
you heard the numbers
yesterday, the number of
devices, you heard the number
of app downloads.
But more importantly, you heard
the number of people in
the world who don't yet have
access to technology.
And as Steve pointed out, as we
start touching that segment
of the world's population that
isn't yet touched by
technology, all of these things
that we're showing you
and that we are showing
you in our sandbox are
really, really relevant.
And in terms of advancing
education, in terms of
advancing access to technology,
in terms of
bettering people's lives, the
impact you have is huge.
And as Alan pointed out, it's
very, very easy to do.
And that's what it is so
wonderful about the
opportunity we all
have together.
ALAN VIVERETTE: Yes?
AUDIENCE: So is this working?
My name is Guarang.
And I've got a question.
Is it possible to switch on
the accessibility features
without necessarily switching
on TalkBack?
Or rather, is it possible to
programmatically switch on
TalkBack within the app?
ALAN VIVERETTE: So let's see.
It is possible to use the
accessibility features without
TalkBack if you have an
accessibility service that is
not TalkBack.
For example, BrailleBack.
It is not currently possible
turn off speech output, but
you can always mute your phone
if you don't want it talking
while you have TalkBack
turned on.
As we showed during the talk,
you can pause TalkBack--
actually let's switch back
to the device real quick.
So you can pause TalkBack by
doing the down right and--
ANDROID: Pause feedback.
ALAN VIVERETTE: --pausing
feedback, at which point
TalkBack is basically
turned off.
And you can turn in back
on really quick.
This is great if you're a
developer and you just need to
do quick testing, switch back to
having accessibility off to
figure out what's
wrong, go back.
Does that answer
your question?
AUDIENCE: Well, actually, what
I was asking is if I want
TalkBack-like features, but I
don't want my users to switch
on TalkBack all the time.
ALAN VIVERETTE: I see.
Yeah, that's a great candidate
for writing an accessibility
service, if you want some of
the features, maybe the
ability to read notifications
out loud as they're received.
And we've seen a lot of great
applications that rely on the
accessibility framework.
I should mention TalkBack
is totally open source.
So if you have any questions
about how something is
implemented in an accessibility
service, you can
check that out again at
eyes-free.googlecode.com.
CASEY BURKHARDT: BrailleBack
as well.
ALAN VIVERETTE: And BrailleBack
back as well is
open source.
TV RAMAN: So to quick round off
that question, those of
you who are familiar with the
accessibility stack probably
already realize this.
So Android accessibility
is layered.
The framework has accessibility
APIs.
It provides things like
accessibility actions, all of
which are covered in
previous talks.
And then you write an
accessibility service that
never adjusts these.
TalkBack is the one that
exercises pretty much every
corner of that API and
those services.
But there's nothing sacrosanct
about TalkBack as the only
accessibility service.
In fact, you actually have to
turn TalkBack on for it to be
active through the accessibility
setting.
So as Alan said, you can
write TalkBack Lite.
You can write TalkBack Deluxe.
You can write TalkBack Lite
Lite, whatever, and get the
experience you want.
And that's how the framework
is created.
So an accessibility service
has three aspects to it.
One is querying what's on the
display, what's in the view
hierarchy, and getting a full
handle on the user interface.
The other is providing feedback
to the user, using
whatever modality they
are using, be that
speech, be that Braille.
And the third is translating
user's intent, such as button
process or whatever into
actions that the system
executes, which is what say a
one button interface would
[? divert ?].
So for instance, if you're
building a one-button
interface for someone who can
see perfectly well, you
wouldn't actually leverage the
speech output capabilities or
the Braille output
capabilities.
You basically have
your one button
interface control the device.
AUDIENCE: Right, right.
Thank you, thank you so much.
TV RAMAN: And one additional
point.
Casey probably demoed
this during his--
but didn't say it
out explicitly.
Because of the separation on
Android, you can actually run
TalkBack and screen
magnification simultaneously.
So a low vision user who both
wants to see the screen
because he can see some and
wants speech output basically
doesn't have to make a choice
saying now I get speech or now
I get magnification.
And the reason why we are
able to do this kinds of
combinations is because of this
layered architecture.
CASEY BURKHARDT: If you'd like
to see a more in-depth demo
screen magnification, please
feel free to drop by the
accessibility sandbox.
ALAN VIVERETTE: Your
question please?
AUDIENCE: My name
is [? Tonson ?].
And I have a question can Google
Play help their brand
man to find apps that has good
accessibility easily?
TV RAMAN: That's a really
good request and we
will take that back.
We've heard that many
times in the past.
Today what we see users doing
is primarily wisdom of the
crowds, which has worked well.
But I agree with you that it
would be really nice to be
able to find apps based on the
user's needs, not just for the
blind user, for instance, an app
that works very well for a
low vision user may not
necessarily work that well for
a blind user.
And it would be nice for users
over time to be able to say
these are the types of things
I'm interested in terms of
user capabilities and find
apps that you like.
So that's definitely a request
we'll take back the Play team.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
ALAN VIVERETTE: All right.
If that's all the questions,
we'll be at the accessibility
sandbox outside.
Again, thank you everyone
for coming.
TV RAMAN: Thank you for
coming, everyone.
CASEY BURKHARDT: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]